out here it is all about our hustle and
that's it
Caitlyn Jenner hosted a screening of
this movie where did you get the chance
to meet her yeah talk to her every week
yeah she's a sweetheart they're
supportive and she gives me good advice
so what kind of advice does she tell you
that she was wonderful so supportive and
just so generous I mean she's a very
busy woman so to make the time to come
out and support our little indie it's
just every means everything in the world
and then on top of that she was able to
have a nice dialogue and discussion with
Maya and I think that they stayed in
touch so you know it's just a really
nice to know that that this film is sort
of making waves across many different
trans communities so it's yeah feels
good she was incredibly gracious and you
know used her entire platform to support
Maya Taylor and we were at the time
running an Oscars campaign for for our
actresses which at the firt at the time
was the first transgender campaign has
ever been run so we didn't get that but
we are here with buku nominations that
the Spirit Awards